at jedi master ray asks if you could
meet one character from the star wars
universe and ask them one question
who would you pick and what would you
ask
i think i would go with rey honestly
just because i want to know she's happy
i want to know she's doing okay i mean i
would have to go with my favorite
character ever big stark lighter
i would ask him how he
made such a glorious mustache it's
something that i
just did for the first time i grew my my
very first mustache and
it was itchy i didn't really care for it
i want to know
how he felt about his mustache hi i'm
alex damon
and i'm molly damon and this is star
wars support
at andy keach asks when did it become
bad
for mandalorians to remove their helmets
in front of people
jango fett is often without his helmet
and in the clone wars you see
mandalorians without them
this was pretty definitively answered in
chapter
11 of the mandalorian where we see boca
tan one of those mandalorians from the
clone wars
she shows up she takes her helmet off
our mandalorian the hero of the show
is all aghast uh and then we learned
that he has been
raised in basically a cult of uh the
mandalorian
people i assume the children of the
watch is related to death watch because
we saw den get
rescued by members of death watch in
season one
kind of an extremist version of
mandalore culture
exactly that uh so it's okay for most
mandalorians to take their helmets off
it's just
that this one sect the children of the
watch
demand that you leave your helmet on at
sarah underscore wolf
maybe something i shouldn't say out loud
says quick question
if i want to start watching star wars in
which order should i watch the movies
i'm always a big proponent of just
release order
yeah me too the the reason i think that
is because
every movie builds on what came before
it even if they chronologically take
place
earlier so yeah there the prequels
i think are better viewed having seen
the original trilogy
uh even small things like rogue one
kind of has a hint for uh the last jedi
a small little easter egg
that you can catch and everything just
does
this little story building thing uh
if you watch it in release order there's
really no wrong way
or wrong order to watch the star wars
movies in but
yeah i think we prefer just release
order date
for a first time viewer i would say
watch them in the order that they were
released
stuart webb asks oh now here's another
question for the real star wars nerds
are all the characters that look like
humans the same species that have
colonized lots of planets
or is it a star trek parallel evolution
thing
and han and leia are different types of
aliens
uh i am not familiar enough with star
trek surprise surprise
to know exactly what the parallel
evolution thing is
i would guess that humans
are the same across the board at least
in legends that coruscant was their home
world
and then they spread out i think it's
probably something
similar here that humanity probably had
a home world and then colonized other
planets
yeah as far as star wars goes and their
species
a lot of them are just described as
human or
every once in a while for instance
dryden boss is described as humanoid
or yeah or near human even uh it
definitely sounds like maybe sometimes
inner breeding has created near human
species
but for the most part i would say that
like han and leia are
the same eric michael garcia says
binge watching clone wars and i have an
important question did obi-wan know
about anakin and padme
i think 100 there's that scene where um
anakin has a hollow call with padme and
rex is kind of guarding the door because
he knows what's going on and then
he's trying to keep obi-wan out of that
room and then obi-wan
later says to anakin something like i
hope you at least said hi to padme for
me like
he knows and there's that moment in
revenge of the sith when
obi-wan basically deduces that padme's
child is anakins
ken collins says i have a question for
all the star wars legends fans
havoc squadron vs delta squadron who
would win
so havoc and delta squadrons were
basically republic commando units they
were very
elite squads of clone troopers we
actually see delta squadron in
the clone wars episode witches of the
mist so they are canon
havoc has yet to be mentioned in canon
as far as i know i like delta squadron
more
i had more experience with them i'm
mostly just choosing them
over my own connection with them i would
prefer that they win
i really liked the republic commando
game yeah i'll go with delta squadron
i mean based off the name alone i want
to pick havoc squadron
okay well a house divided
at tail stake says star wars lore
question
the jedi are a religion right do you
have to be force sensitive to practice
the religion
if someone is born without force
sensitivity but still adheres to the
teachings would they be recognized as a
non-force using jedi in canon we don't
really know a whole lot about the
history of the jedi uh in legends there
was a
whole thing with the tho yore and like
basically a bunch of
people around the galaxy like felt the
calling of the force and it brought them
all to this one place
where they started the jedi religion and
that evolved into the jedi
for canon we don't really know how the
first jedi
were on octo we don't know if they were
all force sensitive or if they were just
trying to access whatever they were
calling the force at that time if they
knew there was something to their galaxy
that they could tap into
it's possible that they were all just a
bunch of dudes that figured it out
yeah there's that mosaic on octo of what
they called the prime jedi but i think
that's more of an example
of what a prime jedi is perfectly
balanced yin and yang there is something
called the church of the force
lor san tekka and the force awakens was
a member of
that so there are definitely people who
believe in the force
but might not be able to touch it in the
same way that the jedi do
i would guess that at least the jedi of
the prequel era would not recognize
anyone that couldn't use the force they
are very
strict rule-based rigid so i don't think
that they would be
like oh you can't use the force but you
still want to be one of us like come on
in i don't i don't see them
trying to nurture anyone in that way
yeah i don't think they would be
considered jedi in that case
the first person that came to my mind
was maz kanata it seems like she has
some connection to the force but she
wouldn't consider herself a jedi
every living being does have some
connection to the force it's like
whether or not you tap into that
well i personally believe that anyone in
the star wars galaxy has
the uh capability to
use the force they just need to be
taught how i mean luke went from not
knowing what it was
to blowing up the death star in like a
day i think that it's on purpose
that in the prequel era we see the jedi
like
testing anakin's blood to be like well
what's his midichlorian count like and
is it worth it to bring him in and i
actually think that is like a fault of
the jedi is that they're
testing potential instead of like
passion if someone is like i want to
become a jedi and it's like i want to
learn this stuff and they're like well
we don't think it's worth the time to
train you i kind of think that's what
the prequel era jedi
what george was trying to say with them
at tavern or cd
says it's time to bring back philosophy
friday with a star wars twist
answer the question was luke skywalker
correct in his assessment of the jedi
during the last jedi
are the jedi fundamentally flawed and
how they approach the force
his first sort of lesson that he gives
to rey
in the last jedi is that the force does
not
belong to the jedi and he talks about
how flawed they were in their teachings
yeah i think that was pretty spot on i
think that
the jedi of the prequel era had lost
their way i absolutely think that that
was george lucas's
intent in the prequel trilogy they were
very different
from the way many of us imagined them to
be when we just saw the original trilogy
and then i think he doubled down on that
when you get into the clone wars series
at rebecca brinker says quick question
for star wars fans
think vader ever fell asleep at a
meeting that should have been an email
i mean he's got the helmet on so who
would know
yes i want that to be true very badly
now
it would depend on his breathing whether
or not people would
notice i guess what do you think snoring
sounds like with that
helmet on i don't know yeah i guess if
he maybe just started to slump over
people would be like hey vader i'm awake
i'm trying to think of of an excuse he
could give in a situation like this like
oh i
had a firmware update
at rabid sola has a question for any
star wars nerds
that would be us uh what is an extremely
expensive
precious material in the galaxy far far
away
that would be equivalent to gold or
diamonds to us
kyber best car those were the first two
that popped into my mind
i think bescar is pretty close because
it seems like everyone
mando comes across and they realize what
his
outfit is made out of they want to
immediately steal it because it's worth
a lot of money
best car is what mandalorian armor is
made out of
uh it's very uh durable
it's nearly blaster-proof the only thing
we've really seen
truly destroy bescar armor is a mudhorn
so far uh but yeah it's
a very precious metal a rare metal that
mandalorian armor is made out of but
also it can be used as currency kyber
crystals
are the crystals that power a jedi's
lightsaber they
were also used to power the death star's
superlaser
they are called living crystals they
have a connection to the force
they would call out the jedi and that's
how they would find
their lightsaber crystal i would guess
that maybe kyber crystals are even more
rare with the jedi not around i mean
even when the jedi were around like
lightsabers on the black market
were highly prized so yeah i
i think you hit the nail on the head
with both of those
i know that there are things that the
comics recently brought back in like
ruby sapphires and the same precious
gemstones
that we have in the real world exist out
there but i mean kyber crystals and
bhaskar
still seem to be more rare and valuable
general clanker says sometimes before
death the separatist battle droids of
the star wars prequels yell
oh my god so that begs the question who
introduced them to religion were they
programmed with religious beliefs
and who is the droid god well i i do
think that
they have some sort of belief system
i mean it might just be something they
say but threepio says
thank the maker yeah i was gonna bring
up the idea of the maker
and i assume that's just who created
them is
is threepio thanking anakin in that
sense
it might just be kind of a thing that
they say like thank the
person that gave me life but there is
definitely
an argument to be had that droids are
sentient i mean l-337 i think proves
that
so i i don't know that the battle droids
were programmed
to have religion but i do think that
it's possible for them to just
develop it on their own without uh
constant memory wipes
at itu studios says very important
question from at blockbuster pod
is this the first sweater in star wars
well
i mean everyone kind of went nuts for
ben solo's good boy sweater
and the rise of skywalker very good boy
uh this might be the first
fisherman sweater though like if like
the first cable knit
yeah i'd say off the top of my head i
can't think of anyone on hoth wearing
one
uh that that feels like the place you'd
see one galen air so kind of has one on
la mu
did they wear them in the holiday
special the the original one
uh no but you you are right about the
the new lego one
vader wears a christmas sweater yeah
it's a lego sweater but it's still
it's still meant to be a sweater my
question with this
mon calamari sweater man though how does
he get it
on and off without just stretching the
the neck hole out
and not to mention their arms their
forearms are huge so how do you get like
your sleeves on they would rip
that sweater apart maybe the back is
just covered in buttons
yeah and it's they just have to button
it up
front to back hector roman says bogatan
has been alive since the first six
movies and she still looks good
question how old is she bo katan is
the sister of duchess sateen crees who
used to be
in charge of all of mandalore she ruled
mandalore space
she was kind of a controversial leader
because she was trying to make
mandalorians uh more pacifist they used
to be
hardcore conquerors and very aggressive
violent people
and she was trying to help her people
evolve beyond that bokeh tan was a
member of a group called death watch
that opposed
the pacifism so bogatan was actually a
mandalorian terrorist for a while but uh
she has since
kind of come around she tried to save
her sister's life and failed and since
then has been
fighting what i would say is the good
fight i think there's still some
darkness in her uh and i hope the series
continues to explore that
my best guess is 50 55
i would say that she could be like 20 at
the very youngest
in the clone wars and then you're adding
about 30 years onto that for the time of
the mandalorian
yeah we discussed this a little bit um
after seeing this amazing episode of the
mandalorian
and i decided that because
mandalorians wear helmets most of the
time she just hadn't hasn't gotten a lot
of
sun damage so yeah she looks great john
carl says not a critique but a genuine
question
prior to the rey trilogy was astral
projection ever established in star wars
either in canon or
legends i can't remember seeing it
before this trilogy for the life of me
this book the jedi path is technically a
legends book but
page 132 talks about a power called
doppelganger
which is exactly what luke does in
the last jedi also you could do it in
one of the old dark forces games where
you play mara jade
uh you could make a doppelganger to
confuse your enemies and like
basically just have a another copy of
you running around fighting
alex geyer says star wars question why
do they call it an x-wing when the
in-universe standard language the letter
for x looks like a triangle
so yes arabesh is the most prominent
alphabet within star wars
uh but it's not the only alphabet there
exists
a i think it's called the high galactic
alphabet
and that is our own so there is an a a b
a c and an x
in star wars and i guess the the people
that make those ships just preferred
that alphabet
hayes brown has a question how does
being strong in the force run in
families if jedi
in theory the most in tune aren't
allowed to have families
i think that the skywalker blood was
kind of
a special case that's definitely how it
started
it was a special case the chosen one he
was probably literally
all that stuff anakin was born of the
force yes and it seems like yeah any
offspring
he had and his line would also just be
very strong in the force
but that is not like a tried and true
definite yes every jedi is going to have
a force sensitive child
if you go back to some legend stuff the
old republic
era revan and bastila
they were two very powerful jedi
and they did have some children who were
force sensitive but if you go down the
line
their descendant satin had a son
theron and he was not force sensitive at
all so
it's not a like a given that uh two jedi
or one jedi are going to have force
sensitive children what a bummer that
would be to be
the only non-force sensitive sibling oh
he definitely had like a complex about
it
yeah alexander yard says good morning
here's a question from my star wars
geeks
what sabach hand was han solo holding
when he won the falcon from lando
they didn't reveal that in solo i'm
going to go
idiots array that's that's the hardest
hand to get
i mean it's got to be either that or
folsom bach
those are the two big winning hands
correct
idiots array is unbeatable full sabacc
is the one that
lando was probably trying to go for
since he was trying he wanted that
little green
cylop yeah i'm gonna assume it was full
sabach but
i think there's also different versions
of savak that you can play
there are yes and even they were said to
be playing uh
numidian prime rules uh while they were
there and yeah
hans gold dice are supposed to be this
is something i was hoping to see because
the visual dictionaries say that his
gold dice
were used for him to win the millennium
falcon in a version of the game called
corellian spike but
we didn't see that happen so that
probably isn't true
that visual dictionary bit got
overwritten but
he never revealed his hand so we don't
know
at dr seekers says here's the real
question does batu celebrate christmas
because i'd love to see how black spire
does the holidays
that's a good question i you know with
all this actual spires i
think it would be neat to have all those
decorated with lights i i bet they
celebrate life day
life day is the star wars equivalent of
the holidays christmas or
whatever you want to call it and it's
traditionally a wookiee celebration
uh them just celebrating life
on their home world of kashyyyk but it
seems like it has spread throughout the
galaxy
a little bit more uh and it's usually
held on november 17th
life day comes from the notorious
original 1978 star wars holiday special
uh that george lucas has since described
as wishing he could hunt down every copy
and destroy it with a hammer
it's a rough watch frankly it's a little
trippy
um but they did recently revise it
and made a lego holiday special
that just came out a couple of days ago
actually and
it's it was just a ball of fun if we're
talking strictly
the batu that we see at galaxy's edge in
disneyland and disney world
i have to imagine they're going to
decorate it during the holidays
maybe we'd see chewie's family there
just walking around the park
but yeah i have to imagine batu
celebrates
life day or some form of it thank you
all
so much for your star wars questions
this has been star wars support